cries of Russia Russia resound across
Simferopol Lenin square
Crimea's pro-russian population is
celebrating the result of the referendum
is this all staged are the flags just
prompts the masses of people a crowd of
extras for 14 days I've been watching us
sometimes frightening drama unfold
I've just landed and emitting to the
center of Simferopol the regional
capital
Vlad who will be helping me during my
visit drives in 1988 zhiguli once the
pride of the Soviet auto industry
this car is not all good to survive the
Soviet Union its spirit is still alive
in Simferopol
especially on Lenin square
a few demonstrators are silently
standing around holding signs this
slogan reads Russia is strong others say
NATO hands off Crimea thanks to our
protectors and Thank You Putin thanks
for what I asked this woman for
protecting us from the criminals who
have taken power and Kiev
Russia must defend us because our own
country can't do it our Crimea is
defenseless I see red armbands being
handed out in a far corner of the square
they read Georgia Nukem or volunteer
militias of the autonomous Republic of
Crimea
supported by groups of Cossacks the
pro-russian Home Guard is forming here
so far they don't make a very
hard-hitting impression
I approached the man who seems to be the
leader of the group I'm the head of the
11th militia company the people
gathering here have appeared for duty to
maintain order in the city they are
workers teachers ordinary citizens of
this city who are helping the Crimean
authorities to guarantee calm and order
after that statement he marches his men
away
what an absurd troop I think
the morning news conference the new head
of government in Crimea has invited the
media Sergei us gone off became de facto
Prime Minister under dubious
circumstances a few days ago armed
pro-russian militias surrounded the
regional Parliament behind closed doors
and in presence of Kalashnikov wielding
gunmen the back-bencher from a tiny
party suddenly became Crimea's leader
other journalists tell me the man is
known for his machine gun like delivery
and is said to have connections to local
organized crime
accion off is a man in a hurry twice
already he's brought forward the date of
the planned secession referendum
today I'm heading south from simferopol
Vlad has told me about a besieged
Ukrainian military base 40 kilometers
away we arrived in time to see the
changing of the guard in front of the
barracks who sent these soldiers they're
not wearing any insignia but they seem
professionally organized and heavily
armed
I asked them if they speak Russian they
continue to march off without answering
a new group of soldiers marches up in
their place for days pro-russian forces
have been blockading this Ukrainian
military base and other strategic
facilities in Crimea
it's a threatening standoff and I hope
nobody is going to make a false move the
Ukrainian soldiers are imprisoned behind
the gates of their own base guarded by
drones Aniki the pro-russian militias
the volunteers at the main gate are
getting ready for the upcoming frosty
nights there's a church on the base the
Archbishop of the Ukrainian Orthodox
congregation of Simferopol one sentry
militias refuse to let the cleric in the
discussion gets louder and more
aggressive archbishop clearance backs
off they're calling us traitors against
the fatherland they say we have no right
to be on Crimean soil even though I
myself am a citizen of Crimea
my ancestors lived here and are buried
here but these people don't listen
they've been stirred up and politicized
they're blinded that makes it very very
difficult to talk with them chef Laura
Nugent aru
next morning at the market in Simferopol
everything seems normal as if there were
nothing wrong
ethnic Russians are a majority in Crimea
making up about 60% of the Republic's
2 million people but for centuries that
Peninsula has been a mixture of many
population groups after yesterday's
events I'm surprised how calm everything
seems everything is normal there are no
problems maybe some people want them but
here in Crimea we absolutely don't need
unrest people are a little worried about
the situation but they are all going to
work as usual
just look around you here are Russians
Crimean Tatars Western and Eastern
Ukrainians all living together in
friendship and peace a moment later the
picture of friendly coexistence starts
to crack some people object to my camera
and there's a heated exchange the
Crimean Tartars seemed to feel most
threatened by the recent developments
why is the situation more dangerous for
the Crimean Tartars than for others
that's because my grandparents
experienced terrible things they were
persecuted and deported from Crimea so
of course I don't want that to happen
again
where's the president if I tell the
centre party prayers in Simferopol the
KBO jame mosque is the religious heart
of the Crimean Tartars community I can
see that this is not a normal Friday for
Crimea's Muslim minority around 300,000
Crimean Tartars now live on the
peninsula
most of them returned to Crimea after
the end of the Soviet Union under Stalin
they were accused of collaborating with
the Nazi Vermont and collectively
expelled to Siberia in Central Asia
after the prayer the Tartars political
leader addresses the crowd he urges them
to remain unified in to boycott the
upcoming referendum the Crimean Tartars
are clearly in favor of remaining part
of Ukraine
my vodka barf is feeling the heat he
bears the responsibility of navigating
his small minority safely through this
huge political crisis he calls on the
west and the United Nations to intervene
on their behalf 45 years after our
expulsion from our home we are settled
here again we are not some people that
appeared from nowhere we are the
original indigenous people of Crimea
here in front of the mosque I met a
young Crimean Tatar he lives on the
outskirts of Simferopol soon even if a
Libya is a law student he's concerned
about what good is Ukrainian law
background will be when Crimea belongs
to Russia
he's older neighbors express anger about
the discrimination they've experienced
from the Ukrainian government especially
during the time when they resettled here
there are disputes over property rights
and building permits for their homes
Ukraine has not done anything good for
us but at least not anything bad
Russia is promising us everything under
the Sun but it's easy to make promises
they're just trying to buy us and then
return Russia wants us to keep quiet and
not say anything against Putin this will
be totalitarianism would totally treason
sudirman invites me to his home he wants
me to speak with his grandmother when
she was six years old she was deported
in a cattle car to the Ural Mountains
tens of thousands of fellow Tartars died
during the explosions in 1944 makhachev
novella is Nellie in Soviet times we
experienced the world only in black and
white no it's important was no color in
life we kept quiet we let and suffered
then our only wish was to return to our
homeland you might be it December white
I will never forget the pain Putin is a
former KGB agent
people like him were shaped by the
Soviet Union a regime that oppressed us
not just us the crimean tatars
there are no people who had good
experiences under Soviet you I'm
beginning to understand what's at stake
for the Crimean Tartars they fear for
everything they rebuilt for themselves
here
back in Simferopol I see more Russian
Cossacks on Lenin square
this evening the revolutionary leader
will be treated to more Russian folklore
suddenly there's a stage at the feet of
the Lenin statue the first flags appear
small ones initially
the ethnic Russian soul is stirring
fanned by a new wind of change
Kamiya belongs to Ukraine they're
calling and rise up Simferopol it's the
first time I've seen a rally by
pro-ukrainian crimeans since the start
of the crisis until now they've been
virtually paralyzed by events and
intimidated by the pro-russian militias
it's International Women's Day and many
of the demonstrators are female and
young
yep Russia would be a step back for me
that is why we are resisting the most
important thing for us is to live in a
free country and to be able to feel free
I don't see that in Russia see at the
controls and there they are
the diginity volunteers there supposedly
here to preserve law and order but to me
they look more like a bunch of hooligans
the police are getting nervous both
groups of demonstrators are marching
toward the regional Parliament the
pro-russian militias have already staked
their claim here
they've been guarding or blockading the
building since the start of the crisis
you can see for yourself how childish
those demonstrators over there are maybe
they don't understand what's going on
well that's up to them
Crimea belongs to Ukraine the protesters
chant in front of a Ukrainian military
facility
flowers chocolate and the Ukrainian
national anthem as moral support for the
security forces these Ukrainian soldiers
have not gone over to the Russians nor
have they quit the service despite calls
from the pro-kremlin Crimean government
to do so we want our boys in there to
see that we're on their side they're
caught up in a war of propaganda they're
being lied to and manipulated now they
can see for themselves and be certain
that we stand together Crimea belongs to
Ukraine the du génie can make another
appearance these Russia shelters are
getting on my nerves it's Sunday morning
I attend a service in Simferopol
Ukrainian Orthodox Church Archbishop
Clemente who I met a few days earlier at
the military base is holding a very
worldly sermon because Putin a criminal
and condemns the Russian media's war of
propaganda Russia has always lied and
deceived everyone when Stalin divided up
Poland with Hitler the innocent people
were shot in the gulag Russia always
lied and unfortunately the world always
believed those lies signal severity
theory later in the day Lenin seemed
satisfied with the developments in his
square
the stage is attracting more and more
people
the show and not just the dance has a
more martial tone than before more
Russian flags are in evidence and now
they're a lot bigger
we'll be better off with Russia Russia
means stability order affordable energy
jobs and peace and that's why Crimea
will go with Russia mr. [ __ ]
together with Russia it says on the
posters they tell the voters exactly
what box to check in the upcoming
referendum many people here seem less
than excited about the referendum they
all know what the outcome will be after
all
60% of the population is ethnic Russian
I pay a visit to a Ukrainian school here
at least the otherwise minority
Ukrainians are in the majority the
curriculum is Western oriented English
and German are taught as foreign
languages but for how much longer is the
question none of the teachers are
willing to be interviewed for fear of
getting into political hot water who
knows there might soon be a new school
principal and a new curriculum but one
of the fathers is relieved to give me
his opinion I don't want to wave flags
for any nationality but I am for a
unified Ukraine
I'll stay positive no matter how the
situation changes I firmly believe that
I live on Ukrainian territory just hours
later the regional Parliament approves
the declaration of Crimean Independence
the pro-russian leadership wants to
hurry it through even before the
referendum
and outing to the Black Sea coast this
is the picture of postcard Crimea the
image that Russians love so much their
holy Crimea
the resort city of Yalta is already
firmly in Russian hands
the choir of Russia's Black Sea Fleet is
performing patriotic songs in the crowd
World War two veterans proudly display
their medals a soviet-era film star has
been flown in to denounce the fascists
in Kiev and Lenin presides over the
pro-russian extravaganza some
overzealous militias try to take down
the Ukrainian flag at first they don't
succeed
Igor sent in the owner of a small
boutique refers to the Russian chanters
as zombies they're the undead risen from
the ruins of the Soviet empire the
Ukrainian is worried about his business
which depends on tourism everyone says
it's more or less a done deal that
Crimea will become part of Russia I
think far fewer people will vote for it
there's a lot of propaganda at the
moment that I'm against it at least so
it won't be a hundred percent news dough
prasanta
on the eve of the referendum the
militias make a show of strength in
Lenin square
the ragtag drew Janicki have almost
become a real army
more than 10,000 pro-russian vigilantes
are supposed to be protecting tomorrow's
referendum from terrorists since there
are no fascists in sight the name of the
enemy has shifted somewhat
Crimea is ready for the great showdown
the flags have multiplied and so his
Soviet nostalgia there is a continuous
historical line Kiev and Roose the
Tsar's of Moscow the Russian Empire the
Soviet Union Russia that is why I am
quite at ease standing under the Russian
and the Soviet flag I was born in this
land
flickering on the government building is
the expected result of tomorrow's
referendum Russia is our home
the Trevi site organized and overseen by
just one of the ethnic groups in Crimea
goes according to plan
official results say 97% of the
participants voted for joining Russia an
election result worthy of Soviet times
today an icy wind is blowing over the
Crimean mountains I Drive out of
Simferopol again to talk with Crimean
Tatars
in the village of commish Korah people
are shocked and angry about the
referendum a spontaneous crisis meeting
in the village centre this man says the
result has been faked the villagers
never even received a polling
notification some people may be
considering leaving Crimea because they
don't want to live in a dictatorship but
for us Crimean Tatars there is no
alternative the Ukrainians can go to
Ukraine but where can we go this is our
land we won't give it up again it's our
land
it's now time for me to leave Crimea my
flight home has to go via Moscow all
direct air links to the West have been
cancelled on my arrival back in Berlin I
will hear the news that Vladimir Putin
has effectively annexed Crimea